In guess we're in Vancouver.
Wow,
alrigth that is daunting.
I hope you'll indulge me here for a
second,
Jordan and Sam have given me the honor
of moderating this debate or discussion
depending on how you view it and I think
that actually creates a certain kind of
responsibility and I want to talk to you
about my responsibility and how I see it
in my.
My sense of how you all have
responsibility in this as well.
I suspect that what's going to happen
tonight is actually historical,
which doesn't necessarily make it good
as lots of
bad history.
It could be good though and that's what
I'm hoping will happen.
So the reason I say I think it's
historical is that we are existing in a
moment where all of the systems that
have helped us make sense are breaking
down the university
systems are breaking down,
journalism is breaking down
and at that same moment we have a
network of people who are trying to make
sense in an alternative way.
And I have to say I think beating the
odds for the moment.
So here's the problem.
That network is not entirely in
agreement with itself about some
significant issues in Sam and have some
differences.
Very difficult.
So what could happen tonight is we could
have some sort of a failure where things
get even more muddled.
We could tread water,
we're nothing gets clearer.
Maybe it would be entertaining,
maybe it wouldn't,
but best case scenario is that we figure
out how to make sense of things that
have gotten in our way before.
And if that happens then you all will
leave here and as you talk in your
various networks,
you will have something to say about in
what way we upgraded our software so
that we could talk more deeply about
difficult issues.
So and to that end we would ask that you
not film tonight's discussion and
broadcast and online.
It's not that we want to hide this.
In fact we encourage you to discuss it,
but we would like to have all of us feel
maximally free to speak here to try out
positions that we haven't tried out
before in the hopes that we can get
somewhere new.
All right,
so
see if we can head towards some of the
discussions that have proved difficult
in the past.
Yeah,
I think I'll just start by saying that
when we first had the idea to do this
now some months ago,
and I'm getting a little reverb,
so if you can dial down then there's a
feed back,
white one,
Jordan and I first decided to do is to
do an event together was after we did
those somewhat ill fated podcasts and I
joked that we would probably need a safe
word for this event.
So
that safe word as will come as no
surprise is lobster.
So
No,
you'll know,
things are dire when one of us says says
that,
but I,
you know,
I just want to express my motive for a
helping to stage these events into it
because I,
you know,
I,
I reached out to Jordan,
and,
um,
it really was born of him in
conversation with people other than
myself.
I saw him do a podcast with Joe Rogan.
I saw him speak to Dave Rubin as I'm
speaking with Brett on Rogan's podcast
and I had so much admiration for him in
those conversations is 90 percent of
what he said in those conversations
struck me as really wise and useful and
well intentioned and 10 percent didn't.
And but I,
and I noticed that it was clear to me
that I am seeing these successful
conversations with other people who I
respect.
I began to wonder that,
you know,
I might be the problem and I,
I think I,
I think I am the problem.
Before you applied,
maybe I didn't mean that quite the way
took it.
I think it's,
I think it's a good sort of problem for
Jordan to have because it's what happens
on those 10 percent moments and what
doesn't happen that I think made our
conversations so hard and,
and I think there is stuff to clarify
between us.
So I look forward to doing that.
And thank you Jordan,
for agreeing to do this.
It's an honor to share the stage with
you and needless to say,
having Brett as a moderator is a,
almost an obscene underestimation of the
role he should be playing at any stage
because he,
as you know,
he's been on my podcast and that was one
of the best conversations I've ever had.
So thank you for doing this.
Thanks.
Alright,
so I'm going to jump right into it.
I think you're.
So look,
this is.
I put up a poll a couple of days ago to
find out what people broadly speaking
might want us to discuss and I'd been
taking a look at that and I took a lot
of notes,
which is why I have my computer here by
the way on my phone.
It's not to check my email.
Well,
the debates going on the discussion.
I thought what I might do is just lay
out some places that I think Sam and I
agree and because there's lots of places
we agree and so and then I want to
figure out where we disagree,
which I've been trying to sort out and
then I want to see if we can hash it out
a little bit and move forward on that a
bit.
So I'm going to lay out.
See,
one of the things that Carl Rogers said,
this psych psych psychologist was that
one good way to have a discussion with
someone is to tell them what you think
they think until they think that what
you said reflects what they said.
We'd like.
This is really useful thing to know if
you're ever having a discussion with an
intimate partner for example,
is that you have to put their argument
back to them in terms they agree with.
It's very difficult.
So I'm going to try to do that.
And so.
So the first thing is,
I think,
I think that partly what's driving you,
if,
if this is accurate,
is that you want to ground a structure
of ethics in something solid and,
and there's two,
there's two things you want to avoid to
catastrophes.
Let's say one is the catastrophe that
you identified with religious
fundamentalism and the other is the
catastrophe that's associated with moral
relativism.
Is that,
is that reasonable?
Yeah,
that's good.
Okay,
good.
Good.
Okay.
Well,
okay.
So it's crucially crucially important
that we get this right now.
So that's something that I think we
really agree on because I've
conceptualized that slightly different
than you and that might be relevant,
but I think of that as a pathology of
order and a pathology of chaos.
So the terminology is slightly
different,
but I think we're working on the same
axis.
So,
so,
so that's the first thing.
And then in order to do that,
it seems to me that's your first
priority.
Then maybe your second priority is
something like,
you know,
you see undue suffering in the world,
plenty of it,
and you would think that things would be
better if that wasn't the case and that
this morality,
whatever it's going to be is at least
going to ground itself in part on the
presupposition that the less undue
suffering in the world,
the better.
So is that also reasonable?
I would just add to that the positive
side of the continuum as well.
So as you know the phrase,
I use the word I use for this as well
being,
and I know from having.
I don't think we spoke about this on my
podcast,
but from having seen in other
interviews,
I think you think that phrase doesn't
capture everything one could reasonably
want,
but I think it does.
I mean I've just,
you know,
it's,
it's an elastic suitcase term for a
reason and it's,
it's actually in reading your book,
I realize there's a point of contact
here because you used the word being
capital b been with as though it were
imbued with significant gravitas.
And so for me,
and I agree with you,
that's an inappropriate use of,
of being a and for me wellbeing is
simply just the positive side of being,
you know,
there's,
there's the negative side,
the suffering we want to mitigate.
But I think I think however good
consciousness can be in this universe,
that the wellbeing for me subsumes all
of those possibilities.
Okay,
well,
so,
so I focused on the suffering element I
think as I've done in my own work
because I actually think it's easier to
zero in on in some sense,
like I think it's easier for people.
And I think you lay out the argument in
the moral landscape kind of like this.
I think it's easier perhaps to gain
initial agreement between people on what
might constitute a generalized ethic to
concentrate on what we don't want.
I'm not saying that what we do want is
unimportant,
but it seems to me to be harder to get a
grip on.
We don't want to Auschwitz,
we don't want to go like archipelago.
So.
And
there are those and I would add to just
closing the door to moral relativism
here.
Those who do want Auschwitz are wrong to
want Auschwitz.
I mean,
obviously it's only happened because
some people did want Auschwitz,
not the victim side,
but the perpetrator side.
And so crucially for me is the claim
that I'm a realist.
I'm a moral realist and realism means is
that it's that there are right and wrong
answers to the question of this kind
and,
and you can not know what you're
missing.
In fact,
we almost certainly don't know what
we're missing on questions of human
value.
And then our job is to discover just how
good life can be and just what variables
are making it needlessly horrible and
to,
to mitigate all of that and live in a,
in a better and better world.
Well,
so.
Okay,
so,
okay,
so that's,
that's a lot of points of agreement.
So I also believe that there is a
catastrophe of,
of arbitrary moral injunction and that
there is a catastrophe of moral
relativism and that,
that,
that has to be dealt with and that there
are genuine differences between the
proper way of behaving morally and the
improper way of behaving morally.
And I think that they are grounded in
human human universals,
even though there's a wide amount of
variation so that that's a lot of points
of agreement,
right?
So we know that there's two things we
want to avoid.
We conceptually speaking,
which is the most moral relativism in
this kind of moral absolutism that's
grounded in an arbitrary statement of
facts that you identify with religious
fundamentalism.
I would identify that with fungilin
fundamentalism more generally,
not,
not with religious fundamentalism per
se,
because I see it also happening,
happening in secular states,
let's say like Nazi Germany or or,
or so.
It doesn't seem to be religious
fundamentalism per se.
That's crucial to your argument.
No,
it's not.
Just to close the loop on that,
the only reason why I would focus on
religion in particular there is that
religion is the only language game where
in fundamentalism and of dogmatism,
dogmatism is not a pejorative concept.
A Dogma is a good word,
and specifically within Catholicism and
the notion that you must believe things
on faith that is in the absence of
compelling evidence that would otherwise
cause a rational person to believe it.
That in a religious context is
considered a feature,
not a bug elsewhere.
We recognize it to be a bug and that's
why the
focus on.
Okay,
so,
so.
All right.
So is it reasonable to assume that the
associate,
we've already established,
at least in principle,
that there's an association between the
totalitarian regimes,
let's say,
and a dog and dogmatism,
dogmatism that characterize his
religious belief.
What do you think,
although it,
at least in principle,
the secularist totalitarian states and
the religious fundamentalists,
totalitarian states do different,
one important regard,
which is that the religious types ground
their axioms in God and the secular
totalitarian types don't.
And so there's got to be something about
totalitarianism per se that's
independent of,
that's associated with religious belief
in the manner that you just described,
but that's not particularly associated
with the belief in God.
There's something that makes them,
it's a commonality between them.
And so do you have any sense of what
that might be?
Well,
I,
I think one has to acknowledge that
there's something uniquely pernicious,
at least potentially about religious
beliefs because they have the other
worldly variable,
the supernatural variable.
The,
uh,
you're gonna get everything you want
after you die.
So this life doesn't matter.
Issue that,
that allows for a kind of misbehavior
that is especially.
Okay.
So,
so it seems that,
so that the claim would be that if you,
if you put forward axiomatically your
claim that God exists,
then you can use that claim to justify
whatever arbitrary atrocities your
system might throw off.
Yeah,
I guess the only point I was making
there is that not all dogmas are created
equal and some dogmas are on their face
more dangerous and more divisive.
Right?
But what I'm curious about specifically
is because it seems to me that the
dogmas of the USSR and the dogmas of
Nazi Germany where as pernicious as any
religious dog dogmas and they may also
share important features with pernicious
religious candles,
but it isn't clear to me from your
perspective what those commonalities
would.
Well,
so I mean in some ways your
recapitulated in an argument I've made,
and this is an argument that I would
make against you.
Were you declaim as you've had you have
elsewhere that,
that atheism is responsible for the
greatest atrocities of the 20th century.
The idea that Stalin,
Ism and Nazi-ism and fascism were
expressions of atheism simply doesn't
make any sense in the case of fascism
and Nazis,
and it doesn't make any sense because
the fascists and the Nazis,
by and large,
we're not even atheist,
mean Hitler wasn't an atheist and he was
talking about executing a divine plan
and he got lots of support from the
churches and the Vatican did nothing to
stop him.
And Fascism as you know,
a coexisted quite happily with
Catholicism in Croatia and Portugal and
Spain and Italy.
So,
but even in the case of stolen,
what was so wrong with that situation
was where all of the ways in which it's
so resembled a religion.
You had a personality cult.
You had dogmatism,
uh,
that,
held sway to a point where apostasy and
blasts with me,
we're killing offenses.
You know,
that the people who,
who,
who didn't toe the line were eradicated
and you know,
so and so to take a more modern example,
North Korea is a religious cult.
It just doesn't happen to be a one that
is focused on the next life or,
or,
you know,
supernatural claims.
So what we imagined if.
Okay,
so what would be the defining
characteristics of a religious
totalitarian movement that would make it
different from a nonreligious
totalitarian movement?
Similar.
Yeah.
They may,
yeah,
they're very similar,
but the problem is dogmatism.
The overarching problem is believing
things strongly on bad evidence and B,
b,
and the reason why dogmatism is so
dangerous is that it is,
it doesn't allow us to revise our bad
ideas in real time through conversation.
It is dogmas have to be enforced by
force or the threat of force.
Because the moment someone has a better
idea,
you have to shut it down in order to
preserve your dog.
Okay.
So,
so the commonality seems to be something
like claims of absolute truth at some
level that can't be,
that you're no longer allowed to
discuss.
Yeah.
Okay.
And so,
okay,
so that's another point of agreement.
Then I would say,
because part of the reason that I've
been,
let's say a free speech advocate,
although I don't think that's the right
way of thinking about it,
just because I think of free discourse,
the discourse that we're engaged in as
the mechanism that corrects totalitarian
excess or dogmatic excess,
and so I also think that systems of
governance that are laying themselves
out properly have to evaluate,
have to elevate the process by which
dogmatic errors are corrected over the
dogmas themselves,
which is why I think the Americans are
right,
say with regard to their first amendment
is the process of free speech is the
process by which dogmatic errors are
rectified.
And so it has to be put at the pinnacle,
the hierarchy of values.
I think you and I totally agree about
the primacy of free speech.
Okay.
Okay,
good.
so that's another.
Thank you.
Okay,
so then we could think there's
point that we should just a lock in our
gains here.
It sounds like what you're saying is
that the reason to fear religious dogma
is really on the dogma side and not the
religion side,
which at least leaves open the
possibility that something could exist
over on the religion side that doesn't
have that characteristic.
Right.
That often they travel in tandem,
but that the thing to fear is not the
religious belief.
It is the dogmatic nature of the way it
is.
The other way to say that is the only
thing that's wrong with religion is the
dogmatism.
If you get rid of the dog,
I've got no problem with the buildings
and the music and the and the
Dan's and.
Wait,
wait,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
That's not a trivial.
It's not a trivial point and it's not
just a joke because the buildings and
the music are very important parts of
their religious process and so I know,
I know there's a humorous element to
that,
but it's not like Sam is throwing out
the baby with the bathwater there
and to go further than that.
I've got no problem.
In fact,
I'm deeply interested in the
phenomenology of spiritual experience,
so,
so whatever experience,
someone like Jesus had,
whoever he was historically or any of
the other,
uh,
Matriarchs and Patriarchs of the world's
religions,
that phenomenology is subjectively real.
I mean,
that is diverse.
I'm not saying everyone's had the same
experience,
but there are changes in consciousness
that explain both how religions have
gotten founded by their founders and the
experiences people have had in the
presence of those people or by following
their methodologies that seemed to be
confirming of the dog.
But that got,
that grew up around those traditions.
And My,
my issue is that whatever is true about
us spiritually,
whatever opportunity being born to this
universe actually presented a matter of,
of consciousness,
a spiritually,
that truth has to be deeper than
accidents of culture.
And just mere historical contingency is
the fact that somebody was born in,
in Mesopotamia and not in China and got
a different language game.
Uh,
so whatever is true,
there has to be understood in universal
terms about the nature of human
psychology and the human mind.
Okay.
So,
so now another thing that I wanted to
just point out obliquely and then I want
to return to outlining maybe where we
agree is that one of the things that was
really shocking to me,
I would say was the my reading of what
was originally Jane Goodall's discovery
about chimp behavior.
You know,
because there is this idea that is
really in Rousseau in thinking that the
reason that people committed atrocities
in the service of their group identity,
let's say their tribal identity was
because culture had corruptive.
So it was a uniquely human thing.
But then of course good all showed in
the 19 seventies that the chimps at
Gombe,
I think I'm pronouncing that correctly,
would go and raiding parties.
Right.
And so there'd be like four or five
adolescent chimps,
usually male,
sometimes with a female in there.
They would patrol the borders of their
territory if they found an interloper on
the border near the border from another
troop,
even if it was a member of their troop
that had immigrated,
so to speak,
and that they knew that they had had
some history with.
They would tear them to pieces.
And of course that was shocking to good
old buddy and my understanding is she
had some trepidations about publishing
it,
although she did,
but then that's been noted repeatedly in
other forms of behavior.
So see,
I've been really interested in the
commission of atrocity in the surface of
belief,
and it's tempting to pin that say on on
Dogma and then to associate that with
religious dogma.
I think that's all tempting,
but the fact that chimps do it shows
that it can't be a consequence of
something like religious belief unless
you're willing to say that the reason
that chimps commit a trustee in the
service of their truth and their
territory is because chimps are
religious and so they're not religious
and they don't really hold a secular
totalitarian viewpoint,
but they act out.
They still act out the atrocity element.
That's characteristic of human behavior.
And so to me,
that makes the problem deeper than one
of mirror,
let's say surface statements surface.
It's of metaphysics.
The obviously the problem of primate
aggression,
which we've inherited along with the
Shims,
is deeper or at least different than the
problem of religious violence or,
or totalitarian political structure is
that,
okay,
get the worst out data people.
So,
uh,
I mean we have,
we have these primate capacities that we
have to correct for and we're busily
trying to correct for almost everything
that we've have been evolved to do and
we're not w w we don't like the state of
nature for good reason.
And virtually everything that's good
about human life is born of our,
I would argue,
culture based and,
and highly intelligent,
unnecessary effort to,
to mitigate what is in fact natural for
us and that,
and there's nothing more natural than
tribal violence,
which you have the source.
You're,
you're describing a chance.
Okay.
So,
so then it also seems like we agree that
the core element of tribal alliance,
which would have its roots say and in
the chimpanzee proclivity to,
or it's analog and the chimpanzee
proclivity to identify with the
dominance hierarchy of the troop is
something that's a source of the
proclivity for human social aggression.
That's independent of it's at in
independent of any obvious religious
substrate.
So there are other reasons for group
belief and the Commission of a trustee
that can't be directly attributed to two
religious dogma.
What most worries me about religion and
I was able to obviously religion can
channel these primal urges in unhappy
ways so you can get tribal violence that
gets amplified by religious dogmatism
and that should trouble everyone,
but it's not unique to religion is also
nationalism and his racism and his other
kinds of dogmatism.
But what most worries me are those cases
where clearly good people who are not
necessarily captured by tribalism per
se,
uh,
are doing the unthinkable based purely
on religious doctrines that they believe
wholeheartedly with without good
evidence.
So you have the person who joins isis
who wasn't even Muslim before they
converted,
you know,
16 months ago.
And they go all the way down the rabbit
hole to the,
the most doctrinaire,
most committed,
most uncompromising view of just how you
have to live in this world.
If you're going to be Muslim and they
join isis based on the idea that
salvation only goes one way and the dine
and defends it,
the one true faith is the best thing
that can happen to you.
There's no question that there are
individuals who have made that journey.
In fact,
there are individuals by the thousands
who have made that journey and they're
far more benign versions of that.
There are people who just waste their
lives.
I would argue converting to whatever the
belief system is and just wasting a lot
of time worrying about hell or warning
about the fact that their child is gay
and the,
you know,
the creator of the universe doesn't
approve of that,
and Oh,
there are all kinds of suffering that
striked me as truly unnecessary born.
Not of,
again,
apelike urges,
but ideas that any rational person would
if believed,
would,
would follow to that same terminus.
I mean,
the thing is if you buy,
if you buy the fact again to take Islam
as as a current example,
if you buy the claim that the Koran is
the perfect word of the creator of the
universe,
never to be superseded by anything
humanity does now or a thousand years
from now that commits a rational per
that then then the exercise of human
reason is bounded by this I would argue
pathological frame which leads to
certain outcomes that we should really
worry us.
So let's take that claim apart for a
minute because that's not your claim
specifically the claim that you were
describing.
See because that's.
That's really not the claim that
religious fundamentalists make.
The claim they make is worse than that
because they claim that the Koran or the
Bible for that matter is the literal
word of God,
but more than that,
they claimed that their understanding of
that word is correct.
Which means they conflate two things.
Because you could imagine a situation
where you had a book,
and I'm not saying this is the case.
It's an imaginative exercise where you
had a book that had all the answers that
was extraordinarily complicated and so
that when you read it,
it wouldn't be obvious that you
understood it or perhaps it wouldn't be
obvious that you didn't understand it
either,
but you're not going to be able to.
You can't get an interpretive version of
the book,
and so the fundamentalists claim is far
worse.
It's that not only is there an absolute
reality truth embedded in the book,
but that their particular take on that
absolute reality is the absolute take on
that book.
So they conflate their own.
They,
they,
they make an assumption of their own
omniscience and then pass that off
quantic
yeah,
except in their defense,
and I don't often rise to the defense of
fundamentalist.
It's,
it's very easy to get there because some
of the claims in the book are not at all
hard to parse.
In fact,
many of them can only be honestly
interpreted one way.
So to take again an example that will be
not inflammatory to you but makes the
point.
It just says that the remedy for theft
in the Koran is to cut the hands off a
thief,
me that you,
that that is the unambiguous injunction.
It's not an allegory,
so the you have to.
You have to dodge some kind of tortured
interpretive scheme to avoid the that
the shocking fact that the creator of
the universe,
he thinks you should live this way for,
for all time,
and people like Isis.
I mean this is my claim,
is this most of what is in these books
and this is what worries me about those
books because they can't be edited.
Most of what's in the books is clearly
not the best that humanity is capable of
in the ethical domain or in the
so
and and so and so clearly,
and this is true for morality,
most pressingly,
but it's true for science,
is true for economic,
is true for anything else that we,
we are wise to pay attention to.
Say Slavery is condoned in the Bible in
both testaments and in the Koran.
There's no getting away from that.
Now you can say,
well,
it's not the central thrust of any of
these books,
but if you,
if you go to the books and try to figure
out what the creator of the universe
wants with respect to the owning and
needless immiseration of other people,
right?
He expects you to keep slaves and he's
told you how to do it.
You know,
don't knock out their eyes and their
teeth.
You don't take if you're a Muslim,
don't take other Muslims as slaves,
but it's not an accident that the people
who joined Isis thought that it was
absolutely kosher to take slaves to take
sex slaves,
and they were even there.
Their use of their sex slaves was
conducted as a sacrament and that's not
an accident.
I mean,
they weren't getting grain over there
that the Fed girls before they raped
them.
So these,
this is not unlike what many people
expect.
It's not that this doctrine is being
used as a pretext for people who would
otherwise do terrible things like take
sex slaves and raped them.
And so there's no net damage being done
here by this belief system.
No,
these are.
I would argue in many cases,
psychologically normal people who are
simply convinced of the absolute
veracity of these ideas and and in in
this case that the perfect example of
Mohammed as the most self actualized
human who's ever existed and what did
Mohammed Mohammed Hooks.
Excellent,
so you know,
he and he's an and then once you,
once you grant that,
and this is,
I mean this is where there's a tension
between both how we pursue the same
goals as we've just established.
We have many of the same goals,
but in so far as you make religion look
palatable in so far as you suggest to
your audience that they can.
They can have their religious cake and
eat it too.
They can,
they can have their reason.
They can have their respect for science.
They can have a 21st century worldview,
but they can also hold on to everything
they love and Christianity or fear to
lose.
And it's undoubtedly mostly
Christianity,
but whatever,
any religion.
My concern is that it keeps us shackled
to these iron age philosophies and these
iron age conversations where we should
be having a 21st century conversation
about everything.
Ethics included.
Okay.
So,
so,
but I want to ask you a little bit about
your feeling about weight before.
Before you move on,
I want to get each of you to clarify
something so that we know we're where we
are.
So Sam,
you said the problem here is that the
dogma can't be updated,
right?
That slavery is with us permanently
because it's written into the dogma,
but clearly most of the traditions in
which it's written into the holy book
don't practice slavery.
And the people who,
uh,
who adhere to these belief systems
wouldn't defend slavery.
So clearly there is the capacity,
an update mechanism,
but not really.
I mean,
they've been forced.
It had beaten out of them,
right?
I mean,
we,
we fought a civil war in the US to get
rid of slavery as Christians who
abolished slavery in England though,
was that it was Christians who were at
the forefront of the movement to abolish
Christians on either side of everything.
I mean there's,
there's no one else to do the job,
but that's the update with specifically
Christians who were using their
Christian belief as a justification for
slavery.
The problem was they were actually on
the
losing side of a theological argument
and it would be much better.
I think you would agree if one of the 10
commandments had been,
don't keep slaves.
Yeah.
I mean there's certainly one week of
swap out for that one,
so
it would've been much easier for
Christians to have fought against
slavery and it's much harder for Muslims
frankly,
to to fight against it.
Now.
The problem is,
is that there's a point I made,
I think in my first book,
is that the,
the doors leading out of this kind of
fundamentalism don't open from the
inside.
They get bashed open from the outside
and it's,
it's,
it's humanism and it's secularism and
it's scientific rationality that has
exerted such pressure,
such winnowing pressure on Christianity,
you know,
now for multiple centuries that that's
why we're not encountering the
Christians of the 14th century on a
daily basis.
The way that we,
we are essentially encountering Muslims
of the 14th century,
a not only in the Middle East,
but in our own societies in terms of
their intuitions about how we should all
live,
right.
I mean,
the fact that zero percent of UK Muslims
think homosexuality is acceptable,
right?
Zero percent,
but there's almost no question you can
come up with the where we could pull
this,
this society and say,
do you think that that the lizard king
is his living in the Oval Office,
you,
you never get a zero percent response to
any
poll question.
Right?
But
if you ask Muslims on the streets of
London,
is homosexuality morally acceptable?
Apparently you can find no one who says
it is.
That's shocking and it's not an
accident.
Right?
And it would be much easier if the book
actually said,
actually you can love anyone you want
and it's not a problem.
It is.
It is shocking.
But I think you know,
there's a reason that you keep finding
yourself at Islam,
which may be the slowest to update for
reasons that may be ancient,
but I want to do that.
That is a useful.
I can't do it for Christianity.
I just want to make the.
I want to make the point as cleanly and
as undistracted loudly as possible.
But yeah,
it made it's true.
I have the same kinds of concerns about
Christianity or mormonism or or anything
else.
And they're all.
The point is they're all different and
there's no reason to be because Islam to
take the case where it's fine.
Islam doesn't represent any impediment
to stem cell research.
Right?
Because they just don't think that,
that,
that the design of the fertilized ovum
is immediately and sold.
They wait.
It's 40 days or 80 days,
120 days depending on what you believe.
So it's just that never came up when we
were all complaining about how religion,
in this case Orthodox Judaism and
Christianity and in the states was
posing and impediment to embryonic stem
cell research.
Okay.
Hold on.
I wanted to ask you a clarifying
question to same level.
Would you agree that there are things
written into these religious texts that
are unambiguously unacceptable viewed
through a modern lens and not because
the texts are so complicated that we
have misunderstood something,
but there are things that are just
written in there that we now understand
to be wrong.
Okay.
So,
so the first thing,
the first thing I would say is that we
have to be very careful about equating
all the religious texts and I do
actually think that you are careful
about that,
but that's something we can have a
discussion about a little bit later.
I agree with you there.
So,
so because you know,
for,
for a lot of my life I was,
I would say more interested in the
universal truths expressed in religious
belief across different cultures.
But I've become more and more aware of
the important distinctions between the
religious cultures maybe in the last 10
years.
So it isn't clear to me that you can
just throw all religious dictum dicta in
the same bucket and there may be complex
reasons for that.
So,
you know,
one question which you kind of sent it,
Sam already,
is,
do you see a hierarchy of
unacceptability between different
religious doctrines?
You active.
Okay,
fine,
fine.
So,
okay,
now,
but here,
here's an interesting issue and I think
we're starting to zero in on.
We've covered what we agreed on a lot of
it,
but there's another way to answer a
question because I think.
Sorry,
sorry,
I answered the first half of it.
The second part is I think that this is
where I'm going to sound like a
postmodernist,
which I really hate.
I would say sentence by sentence.
Yes,
you're correct.
Paragraph by paragraph perhaps.
But here's,
here's the problem with complicated
texts,
especially ones that actually constitute
narratives.
So imagine,
imagine this.
So imagine you're at a movie and it's a
movie with a twist at the end.
And so the entire movie is set up to
make you think one particular way and to
have one set of experiences,
but when you put the twist at the end,
it changes the entire structure.
And so this is the one of the complex
problems that actually led to the rise
of postmodern interpretations of
literature,
which is that if you take a complex
narrative,
there's a very large number of ways of
interpreting it and it isn't self
evident which of those are canonically
correct.
We can deal with that horrible issue
later,
but.
But it's a good objection and it's true.
And what it does is it makes these sorts
of things quite complicated because in
the Bible is a series of books and they
had influence on one another and they
were sequenced with a very complex
editorial process and there's actually a
developmental narrative that links all
the chapters together.
And what that means.
This is at least I'm going to speak from
the perspective or in terms of analysis
of the Christian Bible.
What it means is that you have to read
the beginning as if it's also influenced
by the end,
which is what,
by the way,
in case you think that I'm weaseling
around here and I'm not,
is that that's exactly what you do.
Every time you read any story,
any work of fiction,
you say,
well,
you're claiming that the Bible is a work
of fiction.
It's like,
don't don't.
That's,
that's just a cheap objection.
That's not my point.
My point is that it's a narrative and
everything in a narrative is conditioned
by all the rest of the things in the
narrative and it is well known.
Like if you're a screenwriter,
for example,
there's an old dictum,
remember who generate it was one of the
great Russians that if there's a a rifle
lying on a table in the first scene,
that it better be used by the end of the
second scene or it shouldn't have been
there at all.
So there's this coherence.
I'm looking for the rifle in your answer
to this question,
one overused.
My point is is that it isn't reasonable
to take a single sentence out of a
coherent narrative and say that stands
on its own or it's rarely reasonable
because you have to interpret the word
in the sentence and the sentence in the
paragraph and the paragraph in the
chapter and the chapter in the context
of the entire book.
You have to do that now you could object
and reasonably so that there are some
sentences that are so blatant that you
can't use context to to what paraphrase
them,
let's say,
but I think you also have to give the
devil his due that the Christian Bible
is a developmental narrative and the
beginning has to be read in light of the
end and that's a.
that's a.
that's a fact.
So what does that do to Moses's laws of
war?
This is not a narrative.
This is instructions about what to do
when you invade a foreign land.
If you intend to take over that land,
you kill every break,
right?
There are other rules in there about
killing husbands and taking the wives.
Yeah,
the old testaments are brutal document.
Absolutely brutal.
And so my point would be,
I don't know that reading that portion,
um,
in
light of the end,
even if you call the end of the New
Testament,
I don't know that it changes Moses's
laws of war and their acceptability
while you take the new testament.
Seriously.
It does because it's a suit.
It's a document that supersedes it.
And I think there's actually technical
reasons but superseded.
I mean,
this is the problem.
Slavery is a very straightforward case
because clearly the,
the,
the Bible thumpers of the South who were
defending slavery with reference to the
text felt they were on firm ground.
And I would just,
I would invite anyone to read what the
New Testament and the Old Testament say
about slavery to see that they were on
fairly firm ground.
That the balance of the,
of the honest reading was on the side of
clearly we can,
we can keep slaves,
right?
Jesus.
Jesus never envisioned a world without
slavery.
And he admonished slaves to serve their
masters well and to serve their
Christian masters especially.
Well,
the English Protestants wouldn't have
agreed with that because like I said,
they were at the forefront of the fight
against slavery.
Okay.
Clean influenced by something outside
the text.
And this is began as you're making this
harder than it is.
And my concern is why?
Right?
But I don't think I am Sam,
because I think that the fundamental
message in the New Testament for
example,
is that so
the old hat,
if we Jews are in possession of a book
that has some diabolical passages that
would be better left out.
You're not going to offend me.
I'm Jewish.
It's not like it's in the old testament
itself and the Jewish Bible.
There's,
there's also the seeds of the same
tension.
So for example,
there's a tension and this would be
attention that's of interest to you
because you,
you stated quite clearly in your book,
in the moral landscape that you don't
want to throw the baby out with the
bathwater with regards to at least to
religious phenomenology.
You said that,
for example,
I still considered the world's religions
to be mere intellectual,
runes maintained at enormous economic
and social costs.
But now I understood that important
psychological truths can be found in the
rubble while I'm trying to find the
important psychological truths in the
rubble and so and so,
but,
but we have to decide also if we agree
about that.
Like are there important psychological
truth to be found in the rubble?
Oh,
absolutely.
Okay,
so so then we can.
But
the problem with revelation that this
notion of revelation,
this notion that some books weren't
written by smart people,
they were written by God,
allows you confines you to taking the
whole tax,
even though the text was cobbled
together over centuries and some for
whole centuries,
but some books we're in the new
testament and then they got thrown out
the centuries later and some books
weren't in and then got put in.
So it's like it's an all too human
process that got us these books in the
first place.
But once they were set to believers,
imagine that you're stuck with every
passage and there are passages in the
old testament.
Tell you to stone up a girl or a woman
who's not a virgin on her wedding night.
Take her to her.
Father's doorstep and stone her to
death.
Right.
And
probably agree that those are wrong.
So yeah,
there was another point,
but you don't.
You don't have to read the book to the
end to know that it's wrong,
but you can get.
You can get that from the paragraph.
Yeah,
but that isn't what I said.
I didn't say you had to read the end to
the end of the book to know that it
needed to end.
You need it to read to the end of the
book to contextualize those statements
within the whole.
I didn't know exculpatory.
There's no exculpatory context as to
those kinds of statements and that's
there is in the Old Testament,
there's a real.
There's a real tension and this is.
I think the tension that would be of
interest to you is there's a tension
between the dogmatic and the prophetic
traditions and I think to the degree
that you're interested in religious
phenomenology,
you find yourself on the side of the
prophetic tradition and the prophetic
tradition has implicitly in it,
what would you call it?
An implicit damnation of those dogmatic
crew,
those cruelly dogmatic rules.
You see that emerge all the time,
well arguably in Christianity,
I think going to see it clearly there in
the old testament with the distinction
between the once again
to Islam,
but but every prophetic,
the notion of prophecy is dangerous and
worth worrying about.
I mean the idea that any ancient book
contains in it,
a perfect description of rightly
interpreted,
however difficult to interpret it.
If you're only smart enough,
you could extract from this text a
perfect window onto the future,
right,
and that that whole generations of
people have lived by the lights of this
cockamamie idea,
right?
That the world is going to end and it's
empty and is going to be glorious,
right?
This is.
This is at the center of most most
eschatology is.
It's just that the,
when the wheels come off,
totally right,
that's on some levels the best thing
that's ever going to happen because it's
showing you that in this case,
Jesus is going to come back and throw
this enters into a lake of fire
and I've read to the end of the book is
pretty scary at the end as well.
I in revelation is,
yeah,
no kidding.
Well,
that's a really good objection,
but you know,
like when I did my lectures on the Bible
last year,
I said they provided the psychological
take on the biblical lectures and that's
what I'm going to attempt to maintain
here because I don't believe that I'm
qualified to make fundamental
metaphysical statements,
but,
but that,
that,
that scene,
that's,
that's limited out at the end of
revelation.
So that's a very interesting book read
psychologically because what it is,
and this is,
we should talk about what we'll.
Let me,
let me,
let me just address that.
Only take a minute and I'll try to be
succinct.
So there's an idea that's expressed in
that book is that it's something like
things are always falling apart in a
fundamental manner.
It's part,
it's built into the,
there's an apocalyptic element to human
life.
We fail in small ways and we fail in
catastrophic ways and everything that we
have,
we lose and we die.
So there's an societies come to an end.
There's an apocalyptic element built
into the structure of human reality and
part of part of what's revealed in that
strange book at the end,
which is like a hallucinogenic nightmare
in some sense,
is that the hero is born at the darkest
point in the,
in the,
in the journey,
and it's a psychological truth and it's
very,
very apt because at at the darkest
point,
this is also why Christ is born near
near the darkest time of the year.
From a,
from a,
from a metaphysical perspective,
there's an idea there that when things
fall apart,
that's the time for the birth of the
hero and the hero in revelation is also
the place where free.
Where we're truthful speech most clearly
manifests itself because in the
Christian tradition,
Christ is identified with truthful
speech and so the notion there is that
redemption under apocalyptic conditions
is to be found in the revelation of
truthful speech.
Which is something that you actually
believe.
Well,
I believe in truthful speech,
but I also believe that you can play
this kind of interpretive game with
almost any text.
That this is this way.
But then you can do it with the world
salmon.
That wreaks havoc with your value from
facts argument.
No,
actually I didn't hear what you just
said.
What was that?
While I said you can.
You can.
You can make exactly the same objection
with the world of facts is there's an
infinite number of facts and there's an
infinite number of potential
interpretations and so pat tracking the
pathway from the fact to a value is
actually impossible.
It's the same argument with regards to
the local.
We'll talk about that.
That I don't think that's a good
analogy.
I.
There are more and less plausible
interpretations of,
of any situation,
any data,
and any text,
arguably,
but the problem is that you can.
You can read into any story,
some apparently meaningful set of
psychological insights,
which,
but you can do that with any set of
facts too.
Well,
no,
I mean there's certain things you can't.
You can't over interpret to your heart's
content and come out any way you choose.
My,
my point is that the.
First of all there are.
This is why fundamentalism always has an
edge over more quote,
more sophisticated theology because the
sophisticated theology is in,
in most cases,
inspired by a more and more modern
recognition that what we can't read it
literally because it either makes no
sense or it makes barbaric sense,
right?
So we have to get away from the literal
and the more you get away from the
literal,
the more you are unconstrained by the
text and you can just broadcast on it.
Anything you want to put there.
And so,
you know,
the,
the literal x,
there's no question that most
generations of Christians who read
revelation expected the world to end in
some literals sense of this kind of fat
phantasmagoria.
I mean,
there was,
there was going to be a beast and it
was.
I mean,
this is our,
you know,
undoubtedly they thought this was gonna
happen in their own time,
you know,
under Rome.
But,
uh,
this is a,
you know,
if you're going to go purely literary on
any of these texts,
you are,
you on some level,
you're playing tennis without a net.
You're just,
you're unconstrained by the text and you
can do with it more or less anything you
want.
Isn't that,
isn't that argument working at cross
purposes with your other argument about.
Well,
no,
because it's always tempting.
First of all,
there are lines that do not announce
their,
that they're susceptible to that
interpretation.
I mean,
yes you can.
You can say,
listen,
Allah does not want us to cut the hands
off of thieves.
He,
he just,
you know,
he,
he meant a,
a cut the,
the,
you know,
the hand of their volition rather than
their actual hands.
Right?
So you're,
you're constraining them rather than
kind of now.
Sure.
Undoubtedly there was some,
some Muslim somewhere who wants to
interpret it that way,
but it gets harder and harder.
The clearer the the line is.
And the problem with all of these taxes
that there are so many principles,
again,
I read revelation any way you want.
It is still a problem that it it,
it is perfectly rational on the basis of
reading that text to expect the world to
end and for Jesus Jesus to be the only
savior of it.
Therefore,
if you happen to be born a Hindu or born
a Muslim or or or born a Jew who doesn't
recognize Jesus to be the Messiah,
you are screwed.
Well,
maternity is a funny thing though.
I mean,
it's a strange thing.
Let's say that one of the things we
already agreed on as far as I can tell
is that the antidote to pathological
dogmatism is,
is free,
truthful expression.
Something like that.
Is that?
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
but one of the things I would say that's
absolutely crucial to Christianity in
particular is the notion that the thing
that's redeeming is exactly that and it
doesn't matter,
so it's universal truth.
Now,
if we both agree on that,
the idea that the free expression of
truthful speech is the antidote,
let's say both denialism and to
totalitarianism.
Then the notion that that might be
embodied in something like the word,
which is truly,
I think the deepest of Christian ideas.
It that why?
How is that not the same claim?
Now let.
Let me elaborate more a little bit more,
more,
more completely.
So here,
here's the strange thing.
First of all,
I agree with you by the way,
about the danger of flying off the text.
Write about as you move away from the
text,
your interpretation gets less and less
constraint and I think it's also the
same danger as move of moving away from
the facts,
which is I think why you want to ground
values and facts.
So I get that argument and I think it's
accurate,
but,
but here's,
here's something strange is that this
notion that redemptive,
that redemption is to be found in
truthful speech is actually embodied in
Christian mythology,
let's say as a personality and not as an
idea.
It's actually something that you embody
and act out.
It's not just an idea and that's why
there's an emphasis on the idea of the
embodiment of the word in flesh.
It's a very sophisticated idea.
I mean it's just,
it's insanely sophisticated idea,
so.
And they will.
And there's one more thing.
Okay,
so look you,
you,
you've made the case and I hope we can
really get to this because this is the
really tough part of our discussion I
think is that you want to ground the
world of values in something that's
true.
We can say objectively true,
but let's just say true for a minute and
I share that desire,
but,
but the problem is,
is that I can't see,
and you actually state this in your
book,
I can't see how you can interpret the
world of facts without an a priori
interpretive structure.
And this is an old philosophical claim.
It's not unique to me.
It's,
it's the claim of Khan,
for example,
that you can't get directly from the
fact to the value because there's an
interpretive framework that mediates
between you and the fact that.
So first of all,
I'd like to know if you accept that
proposition.
And then the second question would be,
if you do accept the proposition,
then what's your understanding of the
nature of the interpretive framework?
Because I think it's best understood,
at least in part as a personality or as
a story for that matter.
So
well,
I think our intuition of truth,
the intuition that there's a difference
between fact and fiction or fact and
fantasy,
the intuition that we are in,
we live in relationship to a common
reality about which our understanding
can converge,
provided we're looking in the same
direction with the same tools.
I think that is certainly deeper than
religion.
It's not best captured by stories.
Uh,
it's,
it.
Even if it,
even if you could,
as a matter of historical fact,
point to its roots in story and myth and
religion,
that's not an argument that it's now in
the 21st century best captured by story
and myth and religion.
I think it's,
it is a fundamental intuition to which
our sanity,
both personally and Inter subjectively
is anchored me to lose a sense of
objective reality is to lose the,
the platform on which you can
communicate with anyone and or,
or,
or rationally expect anything to happen
a moment from now to think that your
memory represents something about a
prior state of the world and your
beliefs represent something about a
possible state in the future.
All of this is anchored to a sense that
there's a difference between knowing
something really and just imagining it,
right?
There's a difference between perception
and hallucination and all of these
distinctions are born of this,
this intuition I think we do have
clearly we have fundamental intuitions
which,
uh,
are either impossible to analyze or can
be analyzed with,
with respect to only other intuitions
which we,
which we deem more rudimentary.
Uh,
we're upon which everything else we do
as a matter of knowledge gathering and
sensemaking is built.
So the intuition that two plus two makes
four,
right?
You know,
you at some point you learn basic
arithmetic and you learn what addition
is.
And it's demonstrated to you with
objects and you're showing,
you're showing,
you take two apples and you take two
more apples and then you have four
apples.
Look,
just count them,
uh,
the,
the intuition that,
that can be generalized to any foreign
objects,
right?
That it's not just a fact about apples,
This is something that we are clearly
designed to have their places where it
might break down,
right?
They might break down and at the quantum
level it might break down.
And in areas where our intuitions fail,
we recognize those failures in science
and mathematics by,
by recourse to other intuitions,
which again,
are unreliable.
But so there is just this fact that we
do pull ourselves up by our bootstraps.
And that's not embarrassing.
What's
the difference?
What's the.
And I'm not trying to trap you here,
seriously,
not so.
So there might be mathematical
intuition's a priorities,
let's say identified time and spaces in
a prior intuitions.
But I think there's a third category of
a prior intuitions that are in fact
stories or their personalities or
stories.
So let,
let me give you an example.
So I'm going to do a quick rereading of
the moral landscape.
So because see,
you talk about g dot Morris argument of
infinite regress.
If you claim that something's good and
you equate it with something,
you can also ask infinitely why the
thing you're equating it with is good.
Now it seems to me that the way that you
step out of that argument,
and correct me if I'm wrong here,
as you tell this,
you tell you tell a story.
I'm not trying to be smart about that.
You tell two stories.
You tell a story about someone who has
an absolutely terrible life.
They're in a,
in a,
in a jungle where nature is trying to
kill them all the time and well,
they're trying to be killed by nature.
Wild nature is trying to kill them all
the time.
Horrible barbaric thugs are making their
life miserable in every possible way.
Okay,
so that's one poll,
let's say.
And then another pool you identify and
these are hypotheticals.
So I guess they're fictions.
That's one way of thinking about it.
Even though they're extracted from real
situations,
they're there,
they're met,
have fictions there.
Met a truths,
that's another way of thinking about it.
You contrast a good life and that's a
life where the person has enough to eat
and enough shelter and you know they
have the things that you would expect
people to want.
You say,
this is a bad life and you say this is a
good life,
and so and then you say that's when you
make a side move,
which I would say is that that's an
objectively verifiable fat.
I would say.
I don't think it is an objectively
verifiable fact.
I think it's a fundamental moral claim
and I think that's where you put your
stake in the ground and I would say when
I read that,
I thought,
well,
if you take your jungle story,
which you've extracted from a bunch of
horrors and compiled and you take your
positive story,
which you've extracted from a bunch of
horrors or a bunch of of of Kwanzaa,
utopias,
let's say in compiled your two thirds of
the way to a landscape of Hell and
heaven while so then why not continue
the abstraction and say,
look,
what we're really trying to avoid here
is hell.
We're really trying to move towards this
heaven.
Yeah,
but.
Oh yeah.
As soon as they do that,
you name it.
Just landscape.
No,
but my name for hell,
this is very interesting because
like the,
you and I were talking,
we were talking about this at dinner.
We're talking about this at dinner and
how the,
the,
the overlap or lack of overlap between
our audiences and so like I just heard
from your audience there and you
might've heard from the odd convert,
but,
but what's amazing to me is so like I
have to do some work to figure out what
point they think you made because.
Wait a second.
No,
no.
Hold on.
And I said if you're going to produce a
fiction,
why not go right to the end?
So did produce a fiction.
It's you,
you can tell stories by way of
communicating certain ideas.
I mean that's obviously,
I'm not saying stories aren't incredibly
powerful and useful and inevitable,
right?
It's like we
wait,
I think you are.
You're not saying.
You might not be saying that they're,
that they're,
they're not,
they're not inevitable.
But you are debating their utility and
power because you know,
you said that you don't need the story
as an intern.
So now we have a few doors open here,
which I think we should wait.
We should extract the most out of these
areas that we've touched and not run on
something else.
So I think there is to talk about the
utility of story,
right?
Which is obviously the fact about the
world and about human psychology that
you're reading a lot into and more into
that.
I'm reading right?
And the people we just heard from love
that you.
Or maybe I'm reading more into it
than
that,
but you talk a lot about the primacy of
stories and you're trying to get me to
admit that they are.
That I even,
I helplessly resort to storytelling to
make my points right.
Well I think is a good place for us to
and I don't want us to get bogged down
by.
I think it's a good place for us to
touch this topic of the distinction
between the literal and metaphorical
truth which you.
I mean,
you might want to introduce it,
but I been [inaudible] that for in my
mind that covers,
this is different emphasis on stories.
Okay,
briefly,
but we are,
we are at,
we are at
60 minutes and we had agreed to go an
hour and 15 before we start q and a.
So I agree that metaphorical truth is
relevant here.
Metaphorical truth is my argument that
there are some things which are
literally false,
but if you behave as if they were true,
you come out ahead of where you would if
you behaved according to the fact that
they are false sense that these things
hover in a kind of intermediate space to
call them false is,
is incorrect.
Right?
And,
and,
and I hear Jordan wanting to call them
true because there are so useful,
but you also call it,
look,
this is what happens in the moral
landscape.
I think.
Tell me about that.
Tell me why I'm wrong,
because I'm really trying to understand
it.
See,
I think you dealt with Ge Moore's
problem of infinite regress by by
staking a moral proposition and your
moral proposition was,
look,
here's a way things can be horrible and
here's the way things can be good.
Can we accept that this is horrible and
this is good and that we should move
towards good?
And if the answer is yes,
we can accept that,
then we can proceed and maybe we can
even proceed with extracting values from
facts,
but we have to accept that a priority
presupposition first and you insist that
we have to accept it because it's
objectively true and I don't think
that's correct.
So
unlimited is get the proposition clear.
So my argument is that the worst
possible misery for everyone is bad.
That's hell.
That's hell is is the religious version
of that.
But I'm just.
You can forget about religion or whether
there's a god or anything else that we
live in a universe that admits of the
possibility of experience.
I'm asking you to imagine a universe
where every conscious mind,
every mind that can have an experience
is tuned to the worst possible
experience for that mind.
For as long as possible,
so there's no silver lining,
there is no.
There are no lessons learned.
Everything that can suffer,
suffers as much as it possibly can for
as long as they can.
Now,
that includes human beings,
includes animals,
and includes future ai that we might
build that can suffer.
It includes beings that we will never
know about.
Right?
So my argument is that's bad.
If anything is bad,
that's bad.
Okay?
We don't disagree that the hell is bad.
If,
if the word bad is going to mean
anything that's bad and you can't say
that's fine,
but it's not a factual claim.
No,
it is is essentially it's a claim about.
So I would argue to you,
and again,
it's hard to impart this intuition if
someone doesn't share it,
but if someone doesn't share this
intuition,
I have no way of interpreting any other
word that comes out of their mouth after
they admit they don't share this.
So just imagine someone saying that
doesn't make it a factual claim.
Notes every.
So again,
you guys are going to get stuck here.
I think you're going to give us.
Give us one more minute.
Okay,
one more.
One more minute.
I don't think we'll get stuck here.
Every claim,
every claim we make about anything,
at a certain point,
if you trace all the tools we're using
down to you,
turtles all the way down to something
that we can't explain and justify,
right?
This is true of physics as true of
mathematics.
I just said it was true of arithmetic.
A good old proved it's true of
arithmetic.
I mean there's that.
We have intuitions of truth that can't
be cashed out by recourse to the system
itself.
Uh,
and it's true.
Morally,
I would argue in this sense that yes,
the worst possible misery for everyone
is bad.
And if you're going to say,
well,
who knows?
Maybe it's good or bad.
What does bad mean with a bad means?
Bad things.
Again,
you guys are going to get stuck.
What does bad I,
I really,
I really think that we're going to go
down a rabbit hole here and this is a
crucial issue.
That's an absolutely.
Alright,
so we're putting our.
We have a mutiny here.
We're at,
we're at war with our moderator.
Give us two more minutes.
Okay,
awesome.
So let me.
But what I mean honestly,
addiction,
that two minutes we won't be any
foreigners.
Okay,
let's bet.
I'll bet you
a dollar.
You're literally playing devil's
advocate here because you don't believe
that it's that hell might be good.
No,
of course not.
Okay,
so it didn't say that so second.
So you will agree that it's bad and this
is an eight.
I would argue that anything you would
say,
if you're going to use the word bad and
good or better and worse or anything,
any,
make,
any value,
judgment about anything it will.
Implicit in those judgments will be an
acknowledgement whether you're going to
acknowledge it or not.
When I put the question to you that the
worst possible misery for everyone is
bad.
You can't use the word bad unless you're
not disagreeing in the least about that.
So it's built into your good and bad in
with respect to every other situation in
life.
Find.
You know,
if,
if you,
if you're going home tomorrow and you're
a bus drives by and cuts your hand off
and you say,
well that was bad.
It only makes sense with reference to
this underlying claim.
Well,
it would be worse if the other hand got
cut off too and everyone's hands.
You're beating a dead horse here,
man.
I agree with you.
So I'm saying that everyone assumes this
epic whether they,
whether they claim to or not.
Okay.
And so and to so to say,
and this is,
this is how I bring g Moore's argument
to,
to end the opera.
He says his argument depends on it being
intelligible at that point to say,
well,
is that really bad?
Is it really bad?
Okay,
well,
what would really band be if,
if the worst possible misery for
everyone didn't get you there,
right?
That there's no,
there's no other space to occupy.
I'm also not disputing the utility of
your move to bring g Moore's infinite
regress to an end.
I'm disputing something very specific.
I'm disputing the issue that that's a
factual claim.
That's all bad.
We should avoid it.
It brings Moore's infinite regress to an
end.
All of that.
It's deeper than a factual claim.
It's just a claim about the claim that
is required to make any value,
judgment intelligible,
right?
Any value judgment.
So,
so it's not an not an arithmetical
claim.
So an aeromedical claim about addition
in this case is,
is now you could say the same thing you
could say when I say two plus two makes
four,
you could say,
but is that a factual claim and there is
some way of jiggering the way you talk
about facts with respect to mathematics,
because I.
well,
it's not a factual claim,
but as it's an arithmetical claim,
it's a mathematical claim.
Well,
I'm also not trying to organize our
myosin this way.
Yep,
fine.
What I'm trying to do is to what I'm
really trying to do,
we need.
See the problem I have with your
argument and this isn't.
I don't mean that you're wrong.
I see what you're doing and I see why
you're doing it.
As far as I can tell,
it's laudable,
but for the problem is,
is that as far as I can tell,
there's problems it doesn't solve and
there's other problems that leaves and
address that don't have to be unsolved
or unaddressed.
And so one of the problems is this
problem of the intermediary interpretive
structure and you,
you already said we need intuitions to
guide our,
our,
our interrelationship with facts because
we've already agreed on that.
So the question is what are the nature
of these intuitions?
And I'm saying some of those intuitions
take the place of stories,
take the form of stories,
but even more than that.
So I'm going to go after the health
thing again.
Okay.
Because you said,
well it's bad and you made sure that I
also agreed with that,
which I do.
I agree with that.
And then it's a point of profound
agreement between you and I,
like I've spent my entire life trying to
understand why people get the worst
things they could possibly imagine in
the service of their dogmatic beliefs.
And so I think that that's not good.
Seriously.
And I'm no fan of moral relativism,
so we're,
we're on the same page there now.
But what I noticed when you wrote the
moral landscape is you,
you tell it,
and I'm not trying to trap you,
you,
you tell a story about it looks to me
like it's a story about heaven versus
Hell essentially.
Let me use that language momentarily.
But it's also a story about good versus
evil.
And this is why is because the question
is,
what's bad about hell?
Now you say the suffering,
it's like fair enough,
man.
True enough but not true,
but not true enough.
So what's also bad about how in addition
to the actions that put you there,
the malevolence that generation,
okay,
well that,
that's part of the sufferings mean.
Oh No,
it's not.
No,
It's not the same as the suffering.
It's not,
it's not the having your hand cut off.
It's the pleasure that's derived by the
person who cut it off.
And that is different.
So.
But that's part of my picture.
But wait,
it's an important distinction.
That distinction is important.
Jordan,
my picture of the moral landscape
includes all of this.
It includes everything that this is why
I don't readily answer to the name of
utilitarian or consequentialist because
the way those those views tend to be
taught,
they tend to take as the in the in the
tally of consequences.
You leave out the psychological
implications of being the sort of person
who would,
who would have sought those consequences
or behaved that way.
Right?
So I would grant you,
and this I'm explicit about this,
whenever I talk about this,
that part of the picture of any
consequentialist discussion of wellbeing
are it is everything about the human
mind and social relationships and
societies born of all the individuals
living together,
everything there that leads to different
states of consciousness.
So it's like like you having you having
a negative intentions towards other
people that give you that,
that produce certain negative actions in
the world.
They,
those intentions themselves are part of
the consequential picture.
Those intentions themselves lead to
close the door to certain kinds of
positive mental states that you don't
have.
Let's say you.
Let's say you don't have compassion
because you wake up every morning just
trying to figure out how to manipulate
people.
Well,
not,
not being able to feel compassion for
other people is a bad thing for for many
reasons.
We could produce and if you get the
usual consequentialist picture just
looks at what's happening out in the
world in terms of the body count and
that's not,
you know,
that's.
It's all part of this picture.
It's all we're all talking.
Anything that can possibly affect a
conscious mind anywhere is part of the
picture that I'm painting that I'm
calling the moral landscape.
Okay?
So I want you to let me step
in.
I,
I think we need to bring you somewhere.
Alright.
I'm gonna Start with you sam.
Okay.
Let's swap out the idea of metaphorical
truth for something a little harder
headed heuristics,
right?
We have [inaudible].
We used them to perceive the world.
They're often highly reliable.
In fact,
almost everything that you believed that
lets you operate has to be a hero stick
of some kind.
I mean,
if you decided to learn to drive and you
got into the car and they said,
okay,
well it's all quarks out there,
right?
You need to understand how parks
interact with each other,
not useful,
right?
What you need,
or some heuristics in which you can
stipulate that there's something called
a vehicle out there and you don't have
to be overly precise about what it is
and you learn to avoid it.
Okay?
The heuristics vary a lot in quality.
Some of them are really good.
The periodic tables are really good.
Okay?
Um,
the idea of a gravitational potential
energy is kind of crappy,
right?
If I have a phone on a table here,
I can tell you how much potential energy
it has by measuring its mass and its
distance from the ground.
But if I've got a whole,
at one depth on one side of the table
and another depth on the other side of
the table,
I can't calculate it because it's a
crappy heuristic.
Works well enough in regular stuff.
Now,
here's the question.
What if these religious texts are
heuristics?
Through which most people simplify
calculations that they are in no
position to do based on the limited
amount that they are capable of
perceiving,
the amount that they understand about
the things that are in play.
So they're deploying these heuristics
may be to reduce,
um,
things that degrade wellbeing.
If it were true that religious
heuristics increased wellbeing by
allowing people to actually on average
operate in the world in a way that,
that increased wellbeing,
what would you say about them that?
Well,
I would worry much less about them
obviously,
and that's why I don't treat all
religions equally there their religions
I literally never think about because
I'm not seeing the daily casualties of
those belief systems.
So.
But you say that as people get away from
fundamental versions of these things,
and I'm not advocating for
fundamentalism here,
but you say yourself as people get away
from the fundamental versions of these
things,
things tend to go haywire and so in,
in essence what you're saying
that lap tend to go haywire and one
says,
well,
I thought I was interpreting
multiplicity of interpretations,
right?
Well,
yeah,
but so people are in search of better or
heuristics.
I think the pressure is,
some of these heuristics are obviously
so bad that there's,
there's civilizational pressure to find
better interpretation and,
and,
but you said that the fundamentalists
have an advantage.
What is that advantage?
Because if you just go back to the text
and say,
listen,
I just want to understand what these
words mean,
right?
You get the first pass the quote literal
interpretation,
right?
And you're not bringing the
armamentarium.
You,
you've brought your,
you've got from the outside,
from other parts of culture to Parse the
tax.
You're just trying to,
if it's an English and you speak
English,
you're just trying to decode the words.
Right?
And when it says,
if your,
if your girl is not a virgin on her
wedding night,
take her to her father's doorstep and
stone her to death.
That you know what stone means,
you know what girl means,
you know what father means and you're,
you're 90 percent there to uh,
an obvious atrocity.
I get the horror of it and we'll get to
that in a second.
But,
um,
but the basic point is to say that the
fundamentalists have an advantage,
is to acknowledge something functional
about those stories which I'm claiming
are going to be some kind of
evolutionary heuristic for living a
life.
Does that make him defensible?
They have an advantage.
It's an advantage that it's an
advantage.
It's a,
it's a mimetic advantage.
It's an advantage that isis has the
advantage when,
when,
when the people who,
who share their interpretation of Islam,
they slightly,
it's why someone like Anwar,
Allah,
locky could,
could make youtube videos that so many
people found compelling.
It's because it's,
it's totally straightforward.
Like the advantages.
Listen that a lot of people spending a
lot of time lying to you about what
these books mean and what the profit and
how he lived.
Right?
I,
you,
you know,
in your heart that my interpretation of
this is correct.
You just read the words,
right?
And there's a strength in that.
There's a,
there's an honesty in that.
there's a,
it's just,
it's clear when it says sacrifice a
goat,
goat means goat,
right?
Like you,
you don't have to do something else to
make goat meat having nothing to do with
goat.
Right?
And so that it's,
it's an.
It's an asymmetric war of,
of if you're going to try to make your
dog knows more and more palatable by
importing stuff that clearly was never
even in the worldview of anyone who
birthed these religions.
You're playing,
you're not doing that because you want
to live even more by God's word.
No.
You found some of God's words
unacceptable.
Right?
And that's an every fundamentalist can
sniff that out and the right to sniff it
out because in fact it is in fact the
motivation.
Okay,
good.
So I think we have.
We've got a tenuous kind of agreement
that there might be some kind of utility
that that utility might be morally
questionable sometimes,
but that there is some reason that
people would resort to a fundamental,
simple interpretation because as they
depart from that interpretation,
things get more difficult and to create
some kind of disadvantage.
While the part of the problem with that
would be that as you move away from the
texts,
you fractionate
the moral belief system and you end up
with a nihilistic city situation.
So as you move away from dogmatism,
you move towards the parallel danger,
which is moral relativism and nihilism.
And so hopefully you can find some
ballots.
So
let me ask you to know.
I want to ask you a question.
Oh yes.
Okay.
And also what time do we actually start
this 10?
I just missed the timecard but I think
we have another couple of minutes.
So
no objective reality to time.
I think actually it's a pretty good
conversation we could have,
but.
Okay.
So here's my question for you is if we
agree that there is some way in which
religious texts carry some kind of value
because they allow people to figure out
how to navigate their lives in ways that
might reduce suffering,
reduced the complexity of the choices
that they have to make.
Presumably you will agree that that
would be consistent with an evolutionary
interpretation that the fact that the
stories themselves are functional would
provide an advantage to those who were
deploying them.
Yes,
so here's the problem,
isn't it then also true that those
stories are responsive to past
environments and so the claim that these
things might be timeless would be
suspect and in fact you would expect a
spectrum of durability.
Some stories would be right in a brief
moment and all that's true.
All that's true.
So far so good.
Well,
so far so good.
This is.
This is actually,
I think quite excellent then because
what we have is a recognition that there
is something to these belief systems
that has to do with practical realities
in the past and we also have an
acknowledgement that we cannot trust in
these things based on simple faith
because even if they aren't can be
certain to have worked at some point in
the past.
We don't know what their relevance is to
the president.
Right.
Okay.
Fair enough.
That's an I would say that's.
That's two things about that.
That's exactly why we're having this
discussion and you see what happens in
the most profound of such texts is the
idea that the process by which your
knowledge is updated has to occupy a
position in the hierarchy of values that
supersedes your reliance on dogma is the
fundamental claim.
That's why,
for example,
in Christianity,
the notion is is that the word is the
highest values and that's embodied word
and that's the thing that mediates
between order and chaos and everything
else has to be subject to that and I
would say that's not a claim that's
unique to.
So for example,
I think because we're,
we're being,
we're being told we're out of time here,
so I want to give Sam his reaction to
that as well and then we'll move on to q
and a.
I'm tempted to just asked Jordan the
question here.
I know this,
it's hard to know what to save for
tomorrow night,
but I feel like we've got 3000 people
sitting here who would really like an
answer to this question.
You say you believe in God,
you have been.
No,
I say I act as if he exists,
you'd say what I say,
I act as if he exists a much more
precise claim.
Okay,
so.
So then what,
what?
But in this case what.
So you act as though God exists and in
addition I've heard you say that I act
as though God exists,
that I can't really be an atheist so
far.
We'll see that the night is young.
So in that sense I'm not really an
atheist.
I've,
I've heard you say this,
some of you is.
Well,
if I were really an atheist I would be
far more poorly behaved and in fact I am
right.
I would be like risk on the cough
committing murders and assuming there
was nothing wrong with it more,
it would be more likely.
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
So.
So that's a big distinction I need to
know more likely.
What was that?
It's a big distinction that you would,
is very different than it would be more
likely.
Taking the safety off the gun is not the
same thing as shooting it.
Right.
The temptations laid open to risk and
would be more at hand.
Okay.
Just as they were to him.
So what in that.
So in what sense do you mean?
What is the God that you act as though
he,
she it exists,
and what is the what?
What is the God shaped thing I must have
in my life to prevent me from being a
quote real atheist?
Well,
okay.
First of all,
I have to point out that there's no
possible way I can answer both those
questions in two minutes.
Well,
it's the same question.
Like what?
What do you mean by God?
Okay.
Well,
I'm going to tell you some of the things
that I mean by God.
We do have to get the quizzes.
I'm going to do this tomorrow.
Maybe this is where we start.
Well,
that was
pretty resentful.
I seems like that constitutes an
audience question,
wouldn't you say?
I tell you what,
I'll tell you what,
let's let's do this,
but let's be deliberate about time.
Okay?
Okay.
Well,
I'm,
I'm going to read some things that I
wrote because it's so complicated that
I'm not sure that I can just spin it off
the top of my head.
And so you'll have to excuse me.
So,
and what I'm going to do is sort of
paint a picture by by,
by highlighting different things.
So now are already made.
One point here,
I made the point that part of the
conception of God that underlies the
western ethos is the notion that
whatever God is expressed in truth,
the truthful speech that rectifies
pathological hierarchies and that isn't
all it does,
it also confronts the chaos of being
itself and generates habitable order.
That's a,
that's the metaphysical proposition,
and that that's best conceptualized as
at least one element of God.
And so I would think about it as a
transcendent reality that's only
observable across the longest of
timeframes.
The longest have iterated timeframes to
your point.
So,
so,
okay,
so here's,
here's some propositions and they're
complicated and they need to be
unpacked.
So I'm just going to read them and
that'll have to do for the time being.
So God is how we imaginatively and
collectively represent the existence and
action of consciousness across time,
as the most real aspects of existence
manifest themselves across the longest
of timeframes,
but are not necessarily apprehensible as
objects in the here and now.
So what that means in some senses that
you have conceptions of reality built
into your biological and metaphysical
structure that are consequence of
processes,
of evolution,
that that occurred over unbelievably
vast expanses of time and that structure
your perception of reality in ways that
it wouldn't be structured if you only
live for the amount of time that you're
going to live,
and that's also part of the problem of
deriving values from fact because you're
evanescent and and you can derive the
right values from the facts that portray
themselves to you in your lifespan,
which is why you have a biological
structure that's like three point 5
billion years old,
so god is that which eternally dies and
is reborn in the pursuit of higher being
in truth.
That's a fundamental element of hero
mythology.
God is the highest value in the
hierarchy of values.
It's another way of looking at it.
God is what calls and what responds in
the eternal call to adventure.
God is the voice of conscience.
God is the source of judgment and mercy
in guilt.
God is the future to which we make
sacrifices and something akin to the
transcendental repository of reputation.
Here's a cool one.
If you're an evolutionary biologist,
God,
God is that which selects among men in
the eternal hierarchy of men,
so you know,
men arrange themselves into hierarchies
and then men rise in the hierarchy and
there's principles that are important
that determine the probability of their
rise and those principles aren't
tyrannical power.
There are something like the ability to
articulate truth and the ability to be
competent and the ability to make
appropriate moral judgements,
and if you can do that in a given
situation,
then all the other men will vote you up
the hierarchy so to speak,
and that will radically increase your
reproductive fitness and the operation
of that process.
Long expanses
of time looks to me like it's codified
in something like the notion of God the
father.
It's also the same thing that makes
women men attractive to women because
men,
women peel off the top of the male
hierarchy and the question is what
should be at the top of the hierarchy
and the answer right now is tyranny as
part of the patriarchy,
but the real answer is something more
like the ability to use truthful speech
in the service of let's say wellbeing
and so that's something that operates
across tremendous expenses of time and
it plays a role in the selection for
survival itself,
which makes it a fundamental reality.
Jordan?
Ivanka,
I just cut in here with one question
that for now
what?
So I was not hearing in that list of
attributes a god who could care if
anyone masturbated.
I was not hearing a God who
depends on what else is stopping you
from doing.
Sam,
sorry,
I missed that.
I said it depends on what else is
stopping you from doing
well.
Yeah.
Okay,
so it's serious.
It's important to do something other
than masturbate.
Yes.
Which is which,
which actually constitutes a problem,
which is harder
sounds.
I'm not hearing a God,
a personal God who can possibly hear
anyone's prayer is much less answer
them.
Right,
and I'm wondering what percentage of
religious people who would say,
Oh yeah,
I believe in God and it's the most
important thing in my life.
What percentage of those religious
people do you think have in mind a god
of this sort you just described
know sam?
It's a good question because when I go
talk to people,
when I,
when I talk to people online and use
exactly this terminology,
millions of people listen,
so it's not so obvious which,
what percentage of people see it this
way?
It's maybe that they have the
intuitions,
but they haven't been articulated.
Well,
I mean this is the problem is what
worries me about this.
So
you.
You could do the same thing with the
idea of,
of,
of ghosts,
right?
So,
so people traditionally have believed in
ghosts.
It's a,
it's an archetype.
You might say the ghost survival of
death is certainly an archetypes and we
know what most people most of the time
mean when they say they believe in
ghosts,
and I say,
I don't believe in ghosts,
and you say,
no,
you do believe in ghosts.
Ghosts are your relationship to the
unseen.
That's a ghost,
so you have a new definition of ghost
that you're putting in in place.
Provided which I have to say,
well,
of course I have a relationship to the
unseen,
so I guess I do believe in ghosts.
You win that argument,
but
that
simply isn't what most people mean by a
ghost most.
You mean using that simplified argument
about my conception of ghost as an
analogy for the proposition that I just
put forward is when I see you do.
I mean maybe you have more to say on the
topic of Guy,
but this is what I hear you doing with
God.
You have defined the God that most
people believe in and we know this is
the God that most people.
I was asked what God I believed in.
I'm asking you
percentage,
yes,
but
you,
you by shifting the definition,
you have robbed the now and the
traditional now of its traditional
meaning and you're giving your
partying to people.
Wait a second.
I mean by traditional meaning,
look,
it's one of the.
One of the elemental claims in the Old
Testament is that you're not even
supposed to under the name of God
because by defining it too tightly,
you lose its essence and so let's not be
talking about what the classical
definition of God is here.
Okay?
It's a historical
starter.
Okay?
Then there's plenty of religions that
can make in my check in with the
audience.
Is the audience all right with us
continuing down this.
Okay,
so can I.
can I jump in here?
Sacrificing
your q and a so that it is at the
expense of q and a that's,
that's given out,
but I
probably worth.
So let me say,
Sam,
I do not believe in a supernatural God,
but the God that I've heard Jordan just
describe.
I do not have any difficulty
understanding why he might care if you
masturbate.
And I also don't have any trouble
figuring out how he might answer
prayers.
Well,
tell me more.
I,
I can tell you,
I can tell you how our prayer might be
answered.
Okay?
But these are so specific.
So good.
Let me do that.
So it'll be interesting.
So I'm not Jordan,
we've not talked about this.
If I
an answer from him that actually would
satisfy me as to what the mechanism of
action might be that,
that,
that'd be pretty interesting.
And if he can tell me what I heard,
I think it would,
it would suggest that that we're not
just making it.
Okay.
So,
so you might like this,
you may be done,
but it's possible.
Okay.
So imagine that.
So let's imagine that hellish situation
that you laid out.
Okay,
but,
but let's,
let's put the extra twist in it because
one of the things that we both decided,
I think was that you also have to build
in the intent into that.
So let's say the hell that we're talking
about isn't the victim of the terrible
massacres that you laid out in the
jungle story.
But a perpetrator,
okay,
so someone who's actually acted in a
malevolent manner,
truly malevolent manner,
okay.
Or,
or maybe perhaps we wouldn't have to
take that extreme case.
We could say,
well,
perhaps you've,
that
any of you,
you've decided that you've seriously
done something wrong and you want to get
away from hail.
You want to make things better.
Okay?
So here's,
here's an exercise you can try.
So what you do is,
is,
is you sit on the edge of your bed and
you say,
okay,
what I did was wrong.
And you have to really believe this,
right?
So you've thought about it's killing
you,
it's killing you.
Now you're a penitent and you're
confessing,
let's say,
and you're confessing to yourself as
much as to anyone and you say,
I really want to know what I did wrong
and I really want to know what I could
do to put it right and I'm willing to
accept any answer that will manifest
itself to me.
Try that.
See what happens.
Yeah,
that's a prayer that will be answered
and it won't be answered in the way that
you want it to be answered.
I can bloody well tell you that.
Okay,
but,
but that.
Well,
what are you communicating with you
communicating with what you do
that that is something that.
That is a process that I'm familiar
with.
It doesn't require any supernatural
explanation.
Certainly.
It certainly doesn't require
that.
We imagine that any of our books were
dictated by the creator of the universe.
I didn't say anything so acquired any
supernatural gifts.
Nobody shouldn't order to require.
My concern was asked to provide an
instance of prayer that worked.
That's what I did.
That's,
that's fully understandable.
In terms of human psychology.
It's not understandable because we don't
know where the answer comes from.
Well,
we don't know where anything comes from.
That's true.
Yeah,
so.
But that doesn't.
That doesn't open
door of we one thing we can know with
absolute certainty that that whoever
wrote the Bible didn't know either and
there's many other things.
He or she didn't know.
Everything else we know scientifically,
right?
So obvious with people.
No one even knew.
No one even knew the brain was involved
in any of this.
Right?
So he probably knew about as much as we
do.
About how the brain was involved in it,
but we've already,
we've already established in some
tenuous way that things that nobody
understands could have evolved into
these stories in some way that would be
useful,
but nobody knew what they were writing
when they wrote it.
The problem is that you can so again
with this has been focused through the
lens of your attachment to Christianity
largely,
but the Hindus,
Hinduism is a completely different set
of stories right now and many of them,
the logic,
the emotional logic,
the psychological import.
Many of them have the opposite valence
from any Christian story,
you would tell the whole notion of like
for instance,
the whole notion of good and evil,
right?
Which has such primacy.
I mean you talk about religion being
deeper than ethics because ethics just
deals with right and wrong and religion
deals with and evil right at bedrock,
okay,
good and evil do not have the same
meaning in the east.
Buddhism and Hinduism do something very
different.
We're willing to accept your definitions
of good and evil.
For the truth is it's just not even evil
is just ignorance.
On some level,
it's just an evil is just you haven't
met any real evil people if you believe
that,
well,
okay,
so then all the Hindus and Buddhists are
wrong about this.
That's possible claim.
I'm just saying that there is over a
billion people who have a religious
system of stories from which they derive
all kinds of meaning to which they're
mightily attached to where we could play
the same game of,
of archetypal interpretation and
valuing,
and yet the cash value with respect to
good and evil is irreconcilable with
what you get from Christianity,
but it doesn't,
it doesn't have to be interoperable.
Right?
But,
uh,
but,
but the point is we live in a reality.
Presumably Hinduism is also useful as a
set of heuristics to be for Hindus and
if he,
if Hinduism as a manner of doctrine and
as a matter of the interpretations of
the Heuristics by the devout in both
systems,
if it Hinduism and Christianity are
irreconcilable,
right,
then there must be a deeper level of
reality that explains why they both
work.
That can't be reducible to Christianity
being true or Hinduism being true.
Right?
Yeah.
That's Sam,
that's there's,
there's absolutely nothing
wrong with that objection.
Like so this is one of the immense
problems obviously,
that that actually leads down the road
to the kind of nihilism that you were
objecting to in,
in,
in the moral landscape.
It's like one of the things that need
you said was,
it's very much apropos to this is that
you know,
it's one thing to have your,
your belief system shattered by the
observation that there are other belief
systems that are incommensurate that
seemed to have equal utility so that
that's.
But it's even worse is that once you
make the observation that there are
other belief systems that have equal
utility,
then it can shatter your belief in
belief systems themselves and then
you're in the postmodern nihilism
landscape and that's a big problem.
Or You could just be in a,
in a more fundamental landscape that
subsumes both
fine.
Let's,
let's hope that that can happen,
but that I would say that's the
landscape that I'm trying to pursue.
Now you said that this is,
that I've been approaching this from a,
from a Christian perspective in this
dialogue and to some degree that's true,
but there are reasons for that,
but I would also say I'm also doing what
you recommend doing because in maps of
meaning for example,
because you said,
well,
what about this problem of multiple
interpretations?
You road maps of meaning
you wrote maps of meaning.
I wrote the moral landscape.
I must've,
I must've missed it.
Sorry,
I must have missed it.
I missed starting to get tired,
but what I tried to do it well,
I tried to address that problem
seriously.
Like it's a really big problem.
Was the problem of multiple
interpretations.
It's the postmodern problem is if
there's an infinite number of potential
interpretations.
Okay.
So.
Oh,
so what do we do about that?
And the answer is it's something you
alluded to,
I'm sorry,
in,
in the moral landscape,
and it's part of the basis of your
argument why these things need to be
grounded in facts.
So because that is part of the answer to
the problem of an infinite number of
interpretations in maps of meaning,
I tried to do what Ian Wilson
recommended,
but this was before he wrote his book.
I tried to use a consilience approach.
So I looked at multiple religious
systems.
I looked at Christianity,
I looked at evolutionary biology,
I looked at philosophy,
I looked at neuroscience and I looked at
the literature on emotion and motivation
and the literature on play that was very
nicely delineated by piaget and I tried
to see where there was a pattern that
repeated across all dimensions of
evaluation,
which is exactly what you do.
For example,
when you use your five senses to detect
something real in the world.
And that's what Wilson recommended was a
consilience approach.
And so my proposition was if it
manifests itself here and here and here
and here and here,
six places,
and it's always the same pattern than
the probability that that pattern
exists.
Independent of my delusional
interpretation is radically decreased.
My claim,
however,
is that many of these things don't
repeat.
In fact,
they're flipped around completely based
on different religious assumptions and
different cultures,
and again,
I would just argue that this is.
We can disband discussion is trying to
dispense with those,
but I'm just saying something as
fundamental as evil doesn't run through
all these cultures and all these
religious traditions.
Then how can you make the claim that
everyone would agree with your
description of what constitutes bad
landscape?
It would be.
It just,
it's just not.
It's not evil in the sense that it's.
There's banter,
there's better and worse.
There's better and worse.
Can we?
There's either universal moral
intuitions or there honest no it.
Yes.
No.
Are some moral intuitions universal?
Yes.
No,
I would.
I would think.
Listen,
we are just human beings,
right?
We're human beings first before we're
Hindu or Buddhist or Christian,
but we can all get indoctrinated into
the religion of our parents.
This is a,
an artifice.
This laid on top of something far
deeper.
That should be obvious.
So.
Right.
So,
so we're trying to get down to what's
deeper.
Okay,
so there may be,
there may be some moral universal's.
Sure.
I think Jordan would know,
but possible that there are some moral
intuitions that are highly specific to
particular
and wouldn't translate over to others.
Yes,
so highly probable because there would
be environment specific adaptations like
the environment specific tool use of
chimpanzees.
Right,
right.
Or maybe it's not even the environment.
Maybe it's the self consistency of the
belief pattern in question,
so I'm sure I would put that in the
broader environment.
It might be a consequence of the
particularities of that culture.
There will be things that look,
think about it like languages,
like many,
and this is kind of an answer to the
problem that you laid out,
which is a real problem.
I'm not trying to deny the problem.
If you look at there's a lot of
languages,
lots of languages.
Look at how different they are.
It's like,
yeah,
at some levels of analysis they're
fundamentally different and at other
levels of analysis,
they're fundamentally the same,
which is how we know that their
languages and you could say,
well,
there's into very large number of
stories.
It's like,
yes,
there are,
but the fact that there's enough
commonality across the class of stories,
the set of all possible stories so that
we can identify what constitutes a story
and I would say that there's enough
commonality across the set of all
possible good stories that we can say,
well,
here's a canonical good story,
which is by the way,
what you do at the beginning of the
moral landscape because you say,
this is horrible,
this is good.
We should move from what's horrible to
what's good.
Say yes,
you're,
you've,
you've taken a fragment of the universal
story and you've made it the axiom of
your moral system,
which is what you should do it,
but,
but the claim that I think is not
helpful,
even though I understand it,
is that that's purely a claim of like of
unmediated fact.
It's like,
no,
there is no need.
There is yes.
Even facts aren't unmediated facts.
I mean you can't hand.
You can't judge something to be factual
without presupposing the validity of
certain intuitions.
Like,
right?
That that causes proceed events,
you know,
so,
or causes precede their effects.
And those intuitions could be wrong.
I mean,
we could live in a teleological universe
where everything is getting pulled into
the future by some kind of attractor.
Right?
And our notion of causation is totally
backwards.
That remains to be discovered.
And we have,
we would use other intuitions to make
that discovery again,
again,
that you do pull yourself up by your
bootstraps and that there's,
there's no branch of science or
mathematics or anything fundamental
logic that can get away from that.
But that's another place.
But given that picture,
that doesn't render all intuitions
equally respectable,
absolutely.
Someone says,
Oh,
I happen to have an intuition that,
that Joseph Smith who saw those golden
tablets and they were,
you know,
uh,
in mormonism is true.
That's not the sort of intuition we're
talking about here.
Your intuition doesn't give you insight
into history.
We could
say,
and this would be an elaboration of,
of,
uh,
Brett's point is that moral intuitions
of the sort that you're describing have
different zones of relevance.
So there's some things
that would only work as an intuition in
very delimited areas of time and space.
Let's say there's a hierarchy of moral
intuitions and the more profound the
intuition,
the more it works as a universal truth
across context,
just like in a scientific truth.
So scientific truth is more profound.
This is why the postmodernist readings
of Thomas Kuhn are wrong,
is that the idea that protons are real
is really fundamental because no matter
what span of time and space that you
pick,
you're going to encounter protons.
It works everywhere.
And then with moral intuitions,
let's say,
or moral a priorities you have the same
issue is some of them are so limited
that they only work here and now and
those are sort of impulsive,
low level intuitions,
a whim even.
But some of them are really,
really deep.
The ones,
for example,
the one that orients you to make the
claim that you made in the moral
landscape,
that the hellish story is bad and the
heavenly story is good.
I would say that's one of the deepest,
most context,
independent moral intuitions which,
which is kind of the claim.
You make access.
You claim that as again,
go back to my fundamental concern here
in the difference with respect to the
difference in how we talk about these
things to call that thing.
God is fine.
That's a god I have no problem with.
Right?
But that's not how most people most of
the time are you using the word and
there's something misleading about that
and that's.
That worries me.
Yeah.
Well,
if,
if the claim,
if the claim that you're making is.
We're all deeply confused about the
nature of divinity and ultimate reality,
it's like,
yeah,
yes.
Clearly.
The other thing we agree on,
I also don't disagree.
I don't disagree.
Look,
I've never said I've never made the
claim that what I'm talking about is
like what other people are talking
about.
I mean it is in some ways,
but I've not made that claim so I don't
see why that's a justifiable criticism.
It's like,
no,
it's a,
it's a criticism can the with respect to
the very likely effects of communicating
in that way because I see the results of
that communication.
It's a little bit.
I mean,
this is going to sound more invidious
than it is,
but this is the kind of thing that I get
into a Deepak Chopra.
Yeah,
Deepak and I agree.
I think it's more invidious than it
sounds actually.
Well,
you're not wearing rhinestone book
classes with you if you graduate to
that.
We'll have more of a problem,
but it's.
Deepak clearly wants to let his audience
believe that everything they're into is
on some level justifiable by his reading
of quantum spookiness.
Right?
So it's all.
So if you want to go out and just buy a
lot of crystals and think they're going
to heal you,
it has something to do with quantum
quantum reality.
Nothing me know,
but saying,
but I,
I think deeply could say if,
if I,
if I got his back to the wall,
Deepak could say,
honestly say,
listen,
I've never said anything about crystals,
right?
I'm not selling crystals.
I've never said they work,
but it's the way in which he's failing
to make the clear differentiation.
The fact that the fact that it takes you
20 minutes
to admit that there is that
a lot of the Bible is filled with
barbaric nonsense.
It took me 20 minutes to it.
We'll go to the tape on that.
These things matter.
These things matter and I'm just saying
it's like you were saying,
if you're.
If you're
parish of one or in a parish of 1000 or
a parish of 100,000
but not in the parish that has anything
in common with the with the Bible.
Thumper is in my country who think that
Jesus is very likely coming back in
their lifetime because he never died and
he's going to judge the living and the
dead and there will be a resurrection
and hell fire and all the rest.
If that's not the game,
you're playing at all.
Own it.
Why?
Why are you?
Why are you all applauding about that?
It's like,
what?
What do you mean to own it?
It's like,
I already made my claim.
It's like I'm not playing a religious
fundamentalist game,
so what's all the applause about so I
don't understand that
and own it.
It's like I was as listened.
I was as clear as I possibly could be
when I delineated my answer to the
question.
Some people say,
well,
what do you mean by God?
Somebody asked you if Jesus one
residence second answer,
but no.
Well forget it man.
When a women.
I think we can actually.
This is a complicated.
No,
I don't want to end on.
I don't want to end on a note of
acrimony,
but someone wants to ask you whether you
thought Jesus was literally resurrected
and you said it would take me 40 hours
to answer that question.
Okay.
That's,
that's,
that's the kind of thing I'm responding
to here.
You don't need to do that.
If you have a clear cut answer to that
question,
I don't have a clear head and if you
don't and if you don't do that,
that connects with many other things
that we still have to talk about.
Yes,
definitely.
Yeah,
and I think because a cause that it
isn't obvious in the biblical account
that Christ was literally resurrected,
so it's not simple.
No.
No,
but if the question is,
do you think he let?
Let's,
let's put it probabilistically.
I mean anything's possible.
I'll tell you that it's possible that he
was physically resurrected.
I mean it's,
it's even pause.
Wait a second.
I did with respect to quantum mechanics,
the point is it would take me 40 hours
to answer the question.
I didn't say that he was.
How's this for an answer?
Almost certainly not you.
What's,
what's,
what's wrong with that answer?
I think I,
I think I know what's wrong with that
answer.
It's,
it's a,
it's a financer and people have been
giving that answer for a very long
period of time,
but the idea doesn't seem
to go away.
Okay,
so that evidence of what exactly.
I don't know.
Well,
I can tell you one thing.
It's an evidence of deep idea.
Let this be the doorway to our next
three hour conversation.
Are they clearly were not sure.
So sure we have.
We have 10 minutes left.
Okay.
Well then let's answer that question in
10 minutes.
So wait,
I want you to trust me,
me,
hear you.
For whatever reason decided I should
moderate,
so I want you to trust me.
For one thing,
you.
You've been doing yeoman's work am.
I really would like to answer that
question,
but I'm trying to figure out if people
seem to think that I'm trying to evade
the question.
It's like not evading the question.
I'm trying to figure it out.
It's a really.
People have been arguing about this for
2000 years.
It's like it's not.
That's a sin.
That's a symptom of the effect of
religious dogmatism for $2,000.
No,
it's not.
Okay.
It's certainly a symptom of that.
It's also partly a symptom of the idea.
The resurrection of Jesus is clearly an
important question,
but you've raised a much bigger and more
pressing question for the audience,
which is whether or not God cares
whether they masturbate.
So
I actually think if we pursue that
answer,
that we will actually wrap this up in a
way that you want to end this on
masturbation.
I think we owe it to them.
So
give me a little leash that the floor is
yours.
Great.
How did I end up here?
All right.
So here's,
here's the question.
Let's just figure out if we
can determine why God might care if you
masturbate.
Right?
So let's suppose that we have a story,
a heuristic of some kind that stands in
for something.
And the story is God is watching.
He sees you always.
He doesn't want you masturbating.
So don't you dare.
What happens,
what happens?
Yeah.
Well it's uh,
it's rubbed rather ineffectual idea.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
I think that story,
but I think the reality was was that you
had people masturbating and feeling
terrible about it and you had a whole
layer of sexual neurosis that we've got
grafted onto human psychology
unnecessarily.
Christianity has a certain type apology
of sexual hang up or a which,
which,
you know,
the contracts have.
So if I understand you correctly,
you are agreeing that a certain amount,
certain number of people will masturbate
some of the,
some of them battling the priesthood and
rape little boys.
I mean that is a piece.
There is stick with the topic,
so a certain number of people will have
masturbated.
They will have thought.
Honestly,
it's the same topic.
I mean the,
the,
the taboos around masturbation,
the taboos around sexuality prior to
marriage,
the taboo around divorce,
all of the taboo,
Taboola browned out of wedlock birth.
The ideal of celibacy in the priesthood.
All of that is a is a just a diabolical
machine of needless sexual conflict and
misery.
Hold on.
Yes.
Okay.
You have to take.
How's the.
How's the whole flood of pornography
thing working out?
Okay.
Yeah,
I will.
I will grant you that.
There is some interpretation that takes
supernatural principles and magic and
other worldliness out of the equation
here.
That gets you some wisdom in the
heuristic.
Yes.
If you're masturbating all the time,
you're not satisfying your,
your monogamous relationship with your
wife or husband.
We wouldn't even need to go there.
Let's just.
You're not procreating and we agree that
a certain amount of masturbation was
present,
was prevented by that story,
which made people fear the consequences
of them engaging in it,
which would result in,
I'm pretty sure less less masturbation,
which means that in seeking a release
which we are physiologically programmed
to seek,
one might end up looking in a more
urgent fashion for a mate.
Right?
So it's.
Oh,
we going to enforce monogamy is a no.
So look,
I'm trying to take you somewhere I
think.
I think there is
way that we can rescue some important
part of what both of you were saying
that can now be reconciled and then
there's a bitter pill for each of you.
I mean that's just the way this looks to
me.
So if we can agree that this makes sense
actually as a fitness enhancing
adaptation,
that this story would result in people
behaving in a way that might result in
the marrying early,
might result in them reproducing earlier
than they would otherwise.
Right.
Then we can understand it as mechanistic
and we can understand what you said that
you know maybe God would care about
whether or not people masturbate because
God is a metaphor for some set of
stories that gets you to behave in an
adaptive fashion,
but the point for you then would be that
Sam is arguing with reason.
We can decide whether or not to employ
this story at this moment,
whether it's a good idea for us to
urgently reproduce as quickly as
possible,
which for example,
increases the size of the population of
the planet.
Whereas delaying reproduction keeps the
rate of population growth down and might
be a better choice for a moment in
history when we have seven and a half
billion people on the planet.
So in some sense,
what I think I see is the religious
story itself make some kind of sense.
If you adhere to it in a manner that you
are obligated and I have no tools with
which to question it,
then you will miss the fact that at this
moment you might want to throw that
story.
Yeah.
For the problem is it doesn't make sense
and this is a problem with these
heuristics in general,
it doesn't make sense for the right
reason and that's why it's not a
reliable guide given other changes in
the world,
but with everything changing,
you want to be making sense for the
right reason.
You don't want it so useful.
Fictions have to be retired at a certain
point.
Useful truths stay true.
I mean if you,
because they're based on your engagement
with reality and so to take your point
about pornography,
which I think is totally valid,
you,
we,
you could have a completely rational
conversation in terms of human
psychology and sociology and what you
want society to look like about the
corrosive nature of pornography,
right?
That's not.
You don't have to be a victorian,
a prude to worry that there might be
something wrong with the infinite
availability of pornography to 13 year
olds and above.
Right?
I mean,
that's A.
I don't know what what's generation of
human beings were raising in the current
environment.
It's.
It's quite worrisome actually,
but again,
you don't have to invoke mythology to do
that and I would say the temptation to
invoke mythologist said,
well,
you actually
no,
how do you do it?
Poseidon really gets pissed off when you
master.
How do you do it?
You don't have any effects to have no
mechanism for controlling about the
effects,
human relationships and your own mind
and your own intention and the way you
view others.
That barely works for sex ed.
It barely works for condom education.
Well,
what was already works like those sorts
of educational interventions to stop
that kind of fundamental behavior have
very little effect when people aren't
nearly as amenable to behavioral changes
as a consequence of rational educational
interventions as you might hope.
I mean,
and that's.
That's part and parcel of the very broad
clinical literature.
They're not as.
They're not as amenable to dogmatic
intrusions either.
I mean they are and living.
That might be a problem and neuro
problems with no because.
Because
there again,
this is just like the problem is that
this,
even if you could make the case that a
dogmatic at attachment to one or another
religion was better,
all things considered than being a
secular,
truly secular and truly rational,
right?
It's vulnerable.
It's vulnerable to every next thing we
find out.
I mean,
that's why it's like you could have said
if you go back 200 years before the germ
theory of disease,
you could have said,
well,
all of these dietary taboos and,
and taboos around,
you know,
hand washing and clint foot washing.
It's actually very wise.
The wisdom of the germ theory of disease
was sort of built into our scripture and
people were survived.
There's a kind of differential level of
survival based on those who really
adhere to these,
these practices and those who didn't.
Okay,
but it one,
it's blind to the actual variables.
Like is there's nothing special about
shellfish necessarily or there's nothing
special about pork necessarily or
whatever the example is.
And once you get the actual variables in
hand,
then the whole edifice comes crashing
down and then you really just want to
understand that.
Right?
Does that work?
Look,
I don't know if.
I don't know if the whole edifice comes
crashing down and it isn't clear to me
that you want to claim that because one
of the things you did say in the moral
landscape,
and I think this is associated with your
interest in spirituality,
is that there is some baby mixed in with
the bathwater.
And the question is how do we,
how do we,
how do we distill that out?
And the objections that you're raising
are the objections that are,
look how difficult it is to do the
distillation.
It's like,
yeah,
absolutely man.
And stuff like I'm a photo of the
enlightenment.
I think you enlightenment types and I
put pinker in the same camp and
radically overestimate the degree to
that was.
That was a cause of sweet.
It's like everyone was barbaric and
superstitious until 1750 and some
miracle occurred and now we're all in
what we all became enlightened.
Like there was
the developmental habit.
I mean with this,
hence,
hence to are complaining about the
problem and most of the world,
most of the world hasn't had the
enlightenment true
look.
I no folded the enlightenment,
but I think that it had a lengthy
developmental history that is radically
underplayed by the people who,
who grounded purely in rationality
is clearly still developing.
My point is we we should be able to
agree that having a worldview guided by
a continuous honest engagement with
reality and so far as we can apprehend
it is better than having a worldview
solidified or anchored to unchanging
ideas that were born of people who had
none of our present tools.
None of our present insights into
anything.
Well,
it depends on.
It depends on the principals.
Like I would say there are situations
where that clearly applies,
but I think there are broad principles
and again,
we should probably stop with this.
I think you have out there because I'm,
I'm,
I'm starting to get tired.
I'm sure everyone else in here is
starting to get tired.
Well,
I'm starting to get tired anyways and I
mean the,
the,
there are,
there are principles,
there are higher order principles of the
sort that I described that you also
appeared to rely on in the moral
landscape,
the idea of these profound moral
intuitions and so that's what I'm after
is what are these profound moral
intuitions and what is their source and
like I'm also perfectly willing to make
the claim and have in fact in,
in detail that these moral intuitions
see that this is a place where we differ
a little bit.
It's like maybe we can go here tomorrow
night.
See,
it seems to me that you,
for you,
for you and your argument is the facts
are laying out there and you can extract
out value from them and we already
described why you want to do that
because you want to at least not move
into the nihilistic direction and you
want to ground them in some sort of
reality.
It's like fair enough.
But the thing is is that the facts as
they are,
have been around for a very,
very,
very long time,
right?
Let's say three and a half billion
years,
the entire expanse of life,
and it's the operation of those facts on
life that is produced,
the a priori implicit interpretive
structures that guide our interaction
with the facts and those a priority
implicit structures that have emerged
out of this evolutionary course,
have a structure that mediates between
us and the facts that cannot be derived
from the facts at hand.
So,
so then the question is what is that
structure?
And it's in both of our interests to get
that right,
because you use that as the source of
moral intuitions like right?
Agreed.
That's the source of moral intuition.
So and
Clint,
clearly what we need to table this for
tomorrow night,
but that's a good guys.
I'm just going to interrupt you.
You guys.
Let's give Jordan Peterson,
Sam Harris and Bret Weinstein.
Have you.
Let's go.
Thank you.
Thanks.